if you've been thinking about buying a
new iPad Pro stop don't do it do not
click that add to card button because
the next iPad Pro that's in the works at
Apple right now is going to be so
massively different that it's gonna blow
your mind and I'm not even kidding so do
not buy an iPad Pro especially the M2
which is an embarrassment of an upgrade
and now let's get into the leaks we have
for the next iPad Pro we just got a
brand new report from Ross young saying
that the next iPad Pro is gonna have an
OLED display and both models are gonna
have an increase in terms of the size
from 11 inches to 11.1 and from 12.9 to
13 inches and there's actually some huge
significance to that and I'm gonna
explain why in just a minute but I do
want to mention that the OLED display is
going to be much better than you think
because right now we have mini LED which
is great it works very very well and it
is extremely bright and a lot of people
say that OLED is not as good because
it's not as bright but these new OLED
iPads are going to be amazing because
they're going to be using dual stacked
OLED panels which means you have one
OLED panel in front of the other and
when they utilize both of them it's
going to allow you to have brightness
just as good as mini LED but it's OLED
so you don't have that halo effect
behind white text when everything else
is black like we currently have on the
mini LED you're not going to have that
problem with these new dual stacked OLED
displays they're going to be absolutely
amazing and I think it's going to be
worth waiting for those to come out just
for the OLED display difference alone
but wait it gets even better now I've
been putting some puzzle pieces together
in terms of everything going on with
Apple's iPad and I believe that these
new iPad Pros are gonna be insane
because of that difference in the
display size now I personally believe
that they're most likely to use the same
11 inch and 12.9 inch chassis that they
currently have because that's the
easiest way to go about it but the
problem is that if they make the bezels
thinner that's going to cause problems
with the face ID sensors that are
jam-packed into those bezels now we
already know that the new iPad 10 came
out and it has a brand new landscape
camera orientation which is amazing it's
absolutely awesome but the problem is
because of that landscape camera they
were not able to put the apple pencil to
Magnetic wireless charger right there on
the side forcing them to stick with the
original apple pencil and the reason
they couldn't do that was because the
camera got in the way of that wireless
charging connector so they completely
scrapped the apple pencil connector
altogether it just chose to have the
camera there now imagine this with the
next iPad Pro I fully believe that it is
going going to have a landscape camera
so it's going to be in that other
position which means the entire iPad
layout is going to be meant for a
landscape kind of magic keyboard
position but here's where it gets
interesting I believe that Apple could
be planning to give the next iPad Pro
the dynamic Island yes the same one that
we just got on the iPhone 14 Pro Models
now what that means check this out this
is actually very very clever the dynamic
island is going to be sitting a little
bit lower into the display and that's
going to allow them to thin the bezels
so we get thinner bezels and below that
little portion of the edge of the
display we're going to have the dynamic
Island and because all of the cameras
and sensors are a little bit lower
further away from the edge they're still
going to be able to keep the apple
pencil wireless charger right there
because the face ID cameras went down
that is the absolute perfect solution
for the problem that we have with the
iPad 10 so we're gonna keep the face ID
sensors with the camera and the apple
pencil wireless charger at the same time
and that's going to allow Apple to give
it the dynamic Island now if you think
about it the reason that we don't have
anything like that right now is because
it's very hard to cut LCD displays like
when we first had the iPhone 10r with
the LCD display with the notch there
were reports that there was a lot of
issues with apple cutting the actual
display because it's hard to do with LCD
and if you think about it a lot of the
displays these days that have hole
punches or anything like that like the
dynamic Island and the iPhone they use
OLED displays which are much more easy
in terms of making cutouts and
everything like that so it perfectly
coincides with the dynamic Island coming
to the iPad Pro when it also gets the
OLED display and that is going to happen
in early 2024 which is Springtime around
Marge which is perfect in terms of the
timeline because it's around 18 months
between every refresh so that matches up
perfectly and with that said Apple
giving the dynamic Island to the iPad
Pros is going to make them feel a lot
different a heck of a lot different with
that Dynamic Island and more useful and
of course OLED is going to be amazing
now in case that Dynamic Island idea on
the iPad Pro is a little bit too crazy
or far-fetched there's actually another
option to this main idea with the
thinner bezels there's actually another
way that Apple can fit in both a
landscape orientation camera and the
wireless magnetic charger for the apple
pencil now there have been rumors of us
getting a new Apple pencil 3 sometime in
the future and I do think it would make
sense to launch with an iPad Pro and I
think the 2024 model would make perfect
sense for that launch now instead of
having the magnetic connector for the
apple pencil right in the center right
where the face ID camera sensors is
supposed to be on that new model they
could split it up into two different
magnetic connectors with wireless
charging coils on the side that way you
could still put your apple pencil right
on top and it's going to magnetically
connect except now you're gonna have a
magnet over here and over here sitting
around the face ID sensors in the middle
which means that face ID is still going
to be within the thinner bezels without
the dynamic Island and everything is
still gonna work out that is definitely
another option which might make more
sense than giving it the dynamic Island
so that might be a more plausible or
reasonable solution to that problem but
on the back we are also expecting Apple
to give us magsafe wireless charging
like we have in the iPhones now that has
been rumored by Mark German and I
believe that this 2024 iPad Pro is also
gonna have that so with that said this
is essentially going to be the biggest
iPad Pro redesign that we've seen in
years definitely a lot better than the
current M2 iPad Pro so if you can wait
until early 2024 then I would recommend
that you do not buy any iPad Pro right
now just sit tight with whatever iPad
you have just get through 2023 which is
going to be an uncertain year and then
in 2024 we're going to get an amazing
iPad Pro update and that is what I
recommend so if you completely disagree
with me on these thoughts then let me
know down in the comment section below
and if you want to see which iPad I
recommend that you buy right now then
use the YouTube product tagging feature
to check it out thanks for watching and
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one
foreign
[Music]